I have here a very very interesting
little book, it's a very thin book
It's the telephone directory
for London for 1880.
It's worth looking at the first page
because it acknowledges
the fact that it uses patents
by Bell, Edison and Crossley.
Do you know there isn't a single
Roberts in this telephone directory.
There's only one Jones,
and there are four Smiths.
Most of the companies involved
are railway companies,
because the telegraph
obviously started along railways,
and they quickly cottoned on
to the use of the telephone as well.
Another interesting feature is that the
phone numbers are listed numerically,
So we have number one two three four,
all the way down.
The very first number
is Harvey Brand & Company,
they had the number 1
in the telephone book.